but we got this most special of all the
guests the 44th president of the united
states
barack obama joins us mr president
welcome to the match
how's your family how you enjoying the
golf so far
everybody is doing great and listen what
a spectacular
view i was in montana a couple months
ago
and uh that is as pretty as state as
uh as we have in the union so you guys
are lucky being up there
how's your golf game mr president right
now are you dialed in
you know uh i think it's fair to say
that it unfortunately i do not make a
living playing goal
but uh you know i've had a chance to
play
uh with larry uh and i brought him good
luck he had a hole in one where we
played
then i played with phil uh
and about two weeks later
he won his latest major so i think i am
generally a good luck charm for other
golfers not necessarily myself
well me and trevor won't take that
personally but thank you for that uh
shout out um tell us i got a chance to
meet some of your kids today
can you expand upon my brother's keeper
because these kids were awesome today
well first of all i just want to thank
uh
you know warner and tnt and all you guys
for
giving this enormous opportunity we've
got
five young men who are part of the my
brother's keepers program that
uh my foundation helped set up the ideas
of disadvantaged young men
uh a chance to expose themselves to new
careers
to to see the world to get mentored
uh to you know have more opportunities
to
go to college and uh you know these
these five young guys from chicago for
them to
be in montana to be able to follow
you guys around and see how a television
program is produced
and to be in you know some of the
most beautiful landscapes in america you
know that's eye-opening to them
and you know you guys are not only
giving these guys an opportunity of a
lifetime
that may change the trajectory of their
lives but i know that
uh you know this match is also
contributing to
being able to help thousands of young
people across the country so
along with the other charities i know
that are benefiting we just want to say
how much we appreciate everything you
guys are doing
hey mr president larry fitzgerald here i
saw earlier i saw cyrus and uh
and and the guys walking around is there
potential that you could be
participating in this event coming soon
look
here's the thing you know
if i
his true competitive spirit king came
out last year so
uh you know it could be that maybe uh
you know if chuck does it one more time
and uh survives that maybe i'll have a
little
more gumption to get out there and try
it myself i like that i like that a lot
chuck the
pressure's on hey well i tell you what
i'm gonna make an executive decision if
you want to be my partner in one of
these matches
i don't care what turner says about it
you can be my partner no
he definitely does not want to be yours
he wants to be your
adversary i would love to see the vegas
eyes on that
okay mr president can you hang in there
we're gonna watch some golf and feel
free to jump in you have a master's
champion here